hello so uh yeah I mean that's a cheap
version I got it
so hello my name is Noel Yee and I'm
here with Michael Kate and pike with the
sticks out podcast and I just wanted to
say thank you for spending time to you
know be interviewed and yeah why don't
you introduce yourself who are you
I'm Michael Keaton pike I guess people
sometimes let me is MCP as well one of
the Fuji I guess staff it is from the UK
not so new school pretty old school how
does that make you feel to be old school
fine no okay it's quite nice
like there's nothing super hard to do
now usually what does that mean there's
nothing that's super hard to learn you
know oh yeah just like I just put a
couple of hours I'm out the globe Matt
don't lose contact is kind of hard ish
that can be hard yeah yeah but like you
know you have a level of experience that
gives you the confidence that you can
learn it mm what I'm saying I think all
right I mean ya know it's kind of like
fans for example has a pretty easy
technique base if that makes any sense
so when all the variations are posted
online it's relatively easy for fan
people to pick up tricks but that
happens earlier with fans and probably
earlier with POI I think context app is
kind of funny like that level of a
achievement of being at a level to do
anything is a little bit higher or takes
a little longer than your average yeah
but as well it's like I've done it if
it's a loan that like once you get over
certain challenges like once you get the
sounds of like landing a matrix or
whatever and you keep getting over those
kind of challenges eventually you just
think yeah I could learn anything if I
just go at it
you know it's like I got that confidence
yeah I guess don't experience you know I
mean yeah yeah that seems like a stark
contrast from your early confidence game
oh but uh so so why don't we I don't
know I mean I don't know I feel like
used to be a little more
self-deprecating and potentially more
for lack of better words in my opinion a
little more insecure of your own
staffing abilities and now it seems like
yeah I got a lot to learn but I feel
confident in my ability to learn it hmm
all right here we go so how did you get
into contact staff Michael um well it
was in Edinburgh in on the meadows which
is just a big park in the middle vendrá
middle of my one of my hacker friends
gave me a little lip five stat and I was
spinning it around that's how I going to
it like no new practice whatsoever just
a lit fire Sam I think was in the
juggling Club at the time I definitely
liked it like juggle and deployed before
I learned staff so then going back to
the juggling Club again and again again
I could see that not many people kind of
did staff and like I felt like it was
gonna take ages for me to get really
good at juggling and also I hated
picking things up off the floor but like
so many people that were into staff when
it would be sick it's a bit like
egotistical be easier to get goods that
stash that it would be like juggling
essentially so what kind of what about
the staff drew you in to the staff you
know I don't know at the time I don't
know I still don't probably don't know
but I know what it throws me into it
Mary
alright what draws you into it now just
I'm just curious because like a lot of
people I think it sounds kind of hippy
but you kind of find your prop that
vibrates with you the most and clearly
staff is probably - gettin swoll
vibrated with you the most so like yeah
why is staff your
crap well it does have this time sight
but I think it's like you're not using
the hands thing and the like just
contact the actual physical contact with
lots of different parts of your body
because it does kind of feel like giving
you a message and it's yeah it's got a
lot of feedback to other parts of your
body that you don't normally get with
like for your juggling which is all just
hands hands hands like especially when I
was learning it obviously and yeah like
the only thing I don't like I would say
about context after I would see things
in like juggling it's like the speed of
change
you can't like really change the speed
of the stat really quickly because it's
so having so long it's got a lot of
inertia to this like some styles of
juggling that would like to be able to
call people I can't because the speed
just won't match oh please you have to
it's like do I mean yeah like lots of
like really fast Club manipulations that
make patents look really interesting but
that's that you can't really get close
to that kind of style I mean yeah I see
I see some of that starting with the way
Meis juggle sticks or some of the
smaller stick juggler contact staff
fusion people that are sort of doing
triple staff contact there's a lot of
quick changes that I'm seeing happen
there but I think that's more because
it's more like a baton at that point yes
a contacts that so who are your biggest
inspirations and you're getting started
just to kind of keep the legend status
who are people like when you're again
started and or now that continue to
inspire you in the contact staff game
well obviously roll started me also
letting contact staff as well blue cat
or blue cat for those yeah no we're all
been now deep notes
yeah and then there was a guy in Leeds
called Kronos no many people know him
but he's amazing or he was amazing
he's kind of got lost into probably
doing something real and least obviously
at least came a little bit later and
yeah yeah so what was just cuz I may
know the answer what was the most
inspiring part about Meis I'm guessing
for you
this is ability to stay off its face and
then just copy something for seafood no
he could just do everything I think
though he has put in loads of practice
obviously yeah but well I think back in
the day there's a lot mystique
surrounding least because you couldn't
really speak English that's all so it
would just be like staring into space
and then trying to show you something
that was like way better than anything
you felt like you could do you know I
mean yeah and he also his practice ethic
takes precedence over often personal
interactions or whether it's a foil or
whatever it is to mean he he goes pretty
hard that's what I find the most immoral
how constant beast practices like and I
don't know if he's been like avoiding
other interactions to do that or it's
just like he gets so focused on it but
that's the part it's amazing me at least
I think it's also he's like I think he
lends five balls a really beautiful high
five ball cascade just get better
acceptably I think that's pretty amazing
as well also is some graphic design
background you can really see it I think
in some of the new teammates yeah
there's a sequences yeah all right so
let me ask you a question he lets go do
some fun ones
what so I've been talking a lot online
with Brett and other folks what do you
think what value do you think that
context app can provide
that's different than dragon staff and
what kind of value can dragon staff
provide that's different than kind
that I get that they're sort of same
same but different kind of vibe but at
the same time I'm just I want to hear
this from you because I think this is
sort of a con like a contentious issue
at least in the states there's a lot of
there's a lot of like just dragons or
dragons tempers that are doing their
thing and then for me unfortunately I'm
more of like a purist I can I've like
learned all the Qi roles with the staff
just to avoid doing dragon staff like oh
yeah I don't know I can do the forward
forward reverse forward like I got all
of them but I can do with the staff but
it you know doesn't look like anything
I'm just curious what do you think is
the biggest benefits of either in
downsides
well the biggest benefit dragon staff is
it it's easier and you can put a lot
more fire on it so when you're doing
chores or whatever it's a lot more
spectacular and it's just like if you go
if people get bored of a gimmick of fire
they don't really gonna get bored of the
gimmick of more fire but when you do
have that big head on it it really gets
in the way like keeping your plane's
nice
so like trying to do a nice clean angel
role like you can't keep the plane
really vertical which really irritates
me and also you can't change rolling
direction very easily so the things like
a steam or anything like that or
anything yeah where you want to do both
directions but the rolling direction has
to change it's really hard obviously
yeah everything that doesn't involve
rolling kinda looks a little bit [\h__\h]
once you've seen it looks a little bad
once you see it rolling so I don't think
it really works for moves that don't
roll so good so it does work amazingly
for head rolls I would say one of the
best tools to run head rolls and head
spins with yeah but I would still prefer
contacts - because I think it's more
versatile I think you can do all of the
dragon staff moves even if they are
harder
and you can do all of the contacts that
moves and because it's just like more of
a line you can keep the plains much
cleaner hey basically yeah
but yeah I think there's a lot of stuff
with dragon staff where you'll be able
to fake it with contacts that like a lot
of the really difficult weaves in dragon
staff you could tell if you you can tell
with the dragon static it stopped
rolling well with the contact staff you
could just fake it
you know it's like it doesn't matter if
it's slow rolling either in the move and
it looks like it yeah yeah no that
sounds a little similar what I've heard
which is that the dragon staff helps you
focus on the rolling aspect yeah and I
think that's a benefit so what is your
ideal staff
I'm just so this is kind of a good
question so there's a you know like you
know you have the diameter of this stick
the length of the stick the weighting
the grip like what in your mind for you
at least maybe not for everybody because
it's kind of like a skateboard but yeah
what is your ideal staff I'd say for me
it's probably like 10 centimeters under
my chin and height it used to be like
chin height but now I think a little bit
lower than that so it's more like 140
centimeters
so I couldn't do inside planes more
easily in the horizontal plane I have
stumpy arms some people have really long
arms I guess it's not mean unfortunately
and so I needed a little bit sure and
then obviously as maximally and we it as
possible and as maximally gripped as
possible what kind of good like yeah
what kind of it was a computer game and
the grip was like zero to a hundred I
would have like a hundred grip so it
like literally spaghetti rolled up your
skin with it so what are using silicon
then now or what yeah unfortunately
silicon used to be a PDM but I got used
to silicon man what are your thoughts
like it what's your thoughts on the new
grip types the squishy grip that's been
going around the the wizard grip or
basically other varieties of that kind
of grip yeah I used to love the wizard
grip I think it still its silicone
coating on it though because it's been
like a year of had it and it's all the
grip is gone it's like smooth yeah even
though it's not physically damaged so I
still I think before the full side of a
neoprene yeah I love that I like the
feeling of the wizard grip but yeah for
me I'm not a prop maker so I just read
that and I hate replacing it cuz you got
a sand down the stick and you cuz it's
got that I don't want it um it makes me
crazy but uh okay yeah someone could do
behind to get on
we had like a five day marathon I'm
trying to get this one piece of silicone
onto my staff because the old stuff
would uh got like UV damage so it kind
of got loose and old and aged took that
off like just trying to like thread it
on you don't use the air compressors but
you don't use the air that's how you
that yeah this is like a residential
house they don't have an air compressor
in well if you had an air compressor you
could put it into the end and it blows
up the grip like it it you slide it
right on so that's what we're doing with
our but also Madison so I've noticed
I've noticed recently you've been
posting all this stuff on your website
which is a piece of paper you're holding
up oh yeah it is but I don't know your
website is what is your website again so
right now it's five staff - tutorials
calm okay
sometimes don't you K sometimes
tutorials don't fire staff don't it yeah
I noticed that
like every once in a while you'll like
blast off with a bunch of effort and
then you know yeah and I personally am
guilty of this and then vanish for a
while and do something different what is
the current iteration of effort like
what are you trying to do in this
current iteration of your website and I
saw some of your downwards
Tech Talk oxide dating words
yeah oh I just suddenly realized that I
had all these old videos obviously just
loads and moves that hadn't made
tutorials for yeah and I wanted to
update the website and then suddenly I
realized that the website needed updated
anyway in terms of the backend to do
lots of new things and then that broke
stuff so then I had to update stuff to
fix the stuff that was broken with the
new version and once I was later I was
like well I might as well fix up all
these old tutorials make animation gif
animations for them and then I was like
well I might as well do it to all these
other videos that I've got as well and
all the old tutorials from 2014 and then
at that point I was like well I should
rearrange everything because he's listed
getting massive and then it kept on
going I still got more stuff to do so
it's just like so your background and I
know this a ferreted your background is
in computer science is that right
computer science and artificial
intelligence yeah and so how did you go
I mean I started letting staff at
university for computer science now for
some fun isn't it so how do you see your
computer science like life interacting
with you're a circus performer now right
is that true yes yeah and like well what
kind of circus performers do you do Oh
fire and ABC and acrobatics usually done
some doubles trapeze that's mostly it
how do you see like your tech life pre
you know I don't know being old and your
current life now being you know I don't
know a circus performer extraordinaire
type how do you see them relating and
how did you apply your college life
university life to your present life I
haven't really applied any of my
computer science
life to my circus place Wow yeah not
even in like mindset it's like being in
to make websites okay that's it like
there's not much computer science in the
circus I would say just like a lot of
technical aspects of like stages and
stuff and like some technical aspects of
making custom props yeah so so so what
keeps you motivated to do staff after 12
years later or if not 15 for you like
what uh like what like how why do you
keep participating in the online you're
a moderator and or admin sorry for the
context after and like like what what
keeps you engaged in this online
community of contact staffing sometimes
I feel like I need to just archive all
the stuff I've learned that's one of the
things that keeps me interested and
sometimes I see people giving really bad
advice or just not being able to keep
things properly I'm just like that makes
me aggravated sometimes you'd love
anything cool he treats I'm gonna learn
you know and so until you have you ever
like you've never pulled a retired from
contact staff move have you have you
ever just like put it down and thought
that was the end and then been like okay
I'm back no no I haven't that's amazing
so so so like what what would you start
a good job so what would you want
contact staff right now we're sitting at
maybe 15 years for you I hate to say
closest for me for to that and in
another 15 years what would you like to
see this context that committee sort of
look like I'm just curious like dick
whatever it's going to look like or what
what like what can ya I'm just curious
like your vision for this contact staff
sort of movement because yeah I'm also
curious I would like to see people
making like better videos I guess
better than what people they don't
really explore what they're doing very
much you know I mean even if it's just
performance they don't really explore it
alone tell me more what do you mean by
explore do you mean research do you mean
research it like if they show a trick
they just show like one direction of the
trick or one variation or you know they
just post a video of all of like slow so
like one song or whatever like they
don't really explore different movements
within their flow or different styles or
stuff like this and then post a video of
that research or post a finished
performance and or you know they don't
really explore the tricks that they're
actually doing or we even you know think
about them very much I think what would
be ways I'm yeah
won't be ways people could do that more
are we talking like make videos in the
tech blog format like Here I am doing
extra canned here like the 40 variations
of X trick is that what I I don't know I
think I was guilty of this when I was
last good at sometimes that's why hello
young direct contacts now you know I
think it just comes with experience or
like BMI time you've done it you get
bored of watching the same thing over
and over again so I'd like to see things
that don't bore me personally you're
right I guess for people that knew well
everything seems new they want to they
want to post it you know yes I think I
want to dig into this research thing a
little bit because I feel that in the
beginning I'm sort of the tech guy I
don't know what basically means I don't
know I just posted variations of the
same trick over and over again but I
wonder like what are ways that you think
that people can like steps that people
can take if you were to offer advice to
people trying to do research and conduct
staff what kinds of things could they do
to sort of I mean I think you've
probably written articles about this
somewhere on your website
but how much other probably written
posts at some point but I don't think
I've written any articles about it yeah
what do you think
how can people be better researchers in
their context F which I'm assuming is
for like a more of guest this is the way
to say it a more holistic understanding
of a technique that they probably are
working on or what are ways that people
can get to that point I think it's
considering yeah considering variations
and having them what I hate to think of
it as a more analytical approach to what
they're doing but more mindful approach
because I feel like sometimes coming to
computer science I always have this
analytical look on things but I think it
helps to you know to break down moves
and see where they're going wrong and to
see you know where they can be like
reversed or nerd you know so you can see
where component parts come in and then
you can you know take them out and try
and do them in isolation or you can try
and put them into other things or you
can try and put other moves into their
police you know I think I feel like that
comes a little bit from coding and
computer science because of like
object-oriented programming a little bit
but yeah stuff like this I think with a
lot of techniques that like jugglers use
anyway like time reversing and mirroring
and trying to do it the other direction
trying to do with the other hand except
for exception that the spinning art
still really do some lunch both in terms
of like research like this like these
kind of circus cool thing as well like
you would do research into your prop or
into your discipline yeah yeah yeah I
think yeah yeah I've been trying to
figure out analytical tools for
diagnosing what's going wrong with them
is in order to try and help learning but
that's quite quite a hard one actually
quite a hard thing to get around because
when you have something else look at
moves it's so so useful
learning that it's hard to be able to do
that kind of self-diagnosed say see
yourself without it like filming it at
the very least you know I mean right
yeah I always think about it I had two
interesting statements are thought about
when you're saying that is uh when you
watch a really good performance or a
good flow video and that's just my
opinion but I feel like I can see the
way the person was thinking when I
watched the thing I know that sounds
kind of weird but like when you watched
a really good juggling performance
you're like oh that next trick was so
related to and I can totally see what
that person even though I don't
understand the research that was
happening on the back end like there's
like some level of like logical
continuum through what they're doing I
feel like I'd seen this a lot with high
level juggling especially you know like
you can see that and I think the same is
true of watching the tech video it's
like Brett for example I would say Brett
is not he's a technically minded thinker
but he's not your average thinker if
that makes sense
like he's not thinking in a straight
line necessarily and you can see the
logic in his videos even if there's no
words that are on top of it or somebody
that would take it to the opposite case
and I think that that's something that
the research can really provide and
especially without learning you meant
something that really I always been
thinking about from the beginning is
what what is it trick like like the
circle that bounds off the boundary of
all context have technique to something
you call it trick is kind of vague right
like you're drawing an arbitrary dotted
line around a thing and I always try to
tell people that you know you can go
even smaller that that trick is made of
individual parts and as you analyze each
individual part of that trick you can
start to like for example in an angel
would be like how are you swinging into
it how are you releasing house on the
body how you catching it right all those
parts may seem like separate parts to
have it they're sort of all one thing
that makes a trick sort of like that one
in many philosophical argument with
understanding an idea so that's just my
idea like for example if you do a halo
and this is something I see so often is
it's kind of a funny thing but I see a
lot of halos that you can do a halo
in wall plain without turning your body
but the trick about a halo is that your
body turns like the plane is made more
available by your body being a part of
it and I think that some of that core
basic technique that I after talking to
Aneta like a lot of that stuff is not
new to them right like a lot of the your
body informs the motion of the staff as
a trained specific spot is like
something that is a part of it but for
context app it's not really there's not
enough teachers out there that are
really teaching contact staff in some
level of technique homogeneous having a
conversation one other like there may be
between you and myself and some
international spinners maybe Dave Baron
and a few other individuals that have
sort of from the old school like Chaz or
like people like from the old school
that are bringing contact staff to the
masses maybe those people might be
bringing some of that understanding but
some of the new people you know I
watched a guy this is great that was a
guy I learned a devil role as his first
trick and get it the first day you
learned it right and I'm just like holy
moly like I'm not saying that's bad but
it's just sort of the sign of the the
times of how people understand things so
yeah it's funny when you find kind of
family of traits that step right into
like a basic that's a great no I mean
right like you don't really have any
need for a prerequisite per se that you
could just go straight in from that
trick like you don't really need to have
learn a halo role to learn an angel it
does help with you know it's not really
necessary yeah yeah yeah I was thinking
you know yeah I was thinking about
darlin you wrote an article a while ago
that I really appreciate it or we were
talking or something but like how
contact staff goes from like staff is on
your body a kristef you stand on top of
the staff right and there's that whole
rolling on the ground kind of hippie
style stuff or one end of the staffs on
the ground the rest is leaning on your
body you know like all the gradations of
staff and you know stick on stick
contact is sort of like you're holding
the staff and the other staff is bounced
on the other stick right it's kind of
thinking about how many iterations of
staffer possible totally is this that's
gonna get away from your body yeah I'll
put money on it there's gonna be three
staff stick on stick contact we're like
somebody is gonna like fold in the third
staff just floating in the air on the
second staff that's definitely like the
three-ball like the ball spinning those
magnets in the back so we'll be fine
maybe forget what its gonna say again
why did you do this to me well we can
ask more questions okay well when you
remember it you let me know uh so like
what would be the biggest pieces of
advice you would give like the new spin
so like I think a lot of people who come
into this don't know who you don't
remember it yeah
that's why it's so hard to break down
contact staff into little building
blocks that you could use to code up a
simulator it because it's all based on
the body and the body is a pretty weird
thing to try and make into like a static
representation you know like all these
moves are just because like the statute
itself is pretty simple is the body that
adds all the complexity to contacts that
and have weirdly shaped is basically
yeah oh it's okay so here we go is that
question again what kind of advice you
want to get someone started when contact
step because like there's a lot of
people who probably are not gonna watch
this but maybe one day they will in like
three years as usual but like when
people are getting started you know
because I think the context that group
has this vibe where there are these sort
of bigwigs for lack of better words and
I'm not saying anyone like is really
like kissing a lot of butt or being
jerks about it like many other Facebook
groups I've seen but I mean like what
kind of advice would you give to like
besides I keep trying to keep practicing
blah blah blah but like what kind of
advice would you give to some new people
that are getting into context that make
it easy for yourself
don't get a painful contact staff one
that's too heavy
or one that's badly weighted and it's
not really a 10-step okay you know we
can easy for yourself get something with
super grip just the right weight for you
just the right Lance - you don't have it
with like spikes at the end having with
nice padded ends you know you don't want
anything that's gonna demotivate you
like and there's nothing quite as the
motivating as almost breaking your nose
you know I mean or hating yourself when
really hard yeah I'm just a repetition
repetition repetition I guess yeah so a
little one often that's the one yeah
sorry
yeah I don't like going like it's been
all day everyday if you want but it's
also fine to try and do it for a little
bit but try and keep that consistently
there like I guess like Dylan what
weakness yeah you plans his name yep
every lunch thing would be out there
spinning can't miss job I assume you
need great weight someone yeah he's a
he's a motivational dude he's one of the
ones we got and the same the same knows
another guy so on the dragon staff group
that did it blend one trick if we say 30
days on trick today everything babies
it's also yeah a little Austin basically
yeah so more valuable practice sessions
or more consistency in your practice
session is better than sort of the binge
practice which which I've something to
say I'm pretty guilty of the binge
practice in my past but I've had to sort
of reform myself to being a more like
let me rock this 20 minutes right now
because my skin yeah yes oh yeah for
sure I mean also loving loving just your
prop is amazing
like when I think for you as well when
you started you probably take your staff
everywhere if you could you know I mean
mm-hmm
just rock around with it all the time
everywhere you go is like
I do staff data like that kind of thing
that really helps in the beginning as
well but after a while if you want to
get really good obviously you have to
sex some kind of consistent practice
which is not as fun but is as necessary
anything
I like that mean loving your prop that's
good yeah if you look at musicians or
like with any kind of high expert level
person at some point yeah they loved it
and then they had to set up a discipline
to practice
you don't think a constant level
musician classical musician got they are
just fine you know practicing on
weekends with their violator whatever
because it really didn't yeah no that's
uh I think about that because it goes
the same way with I don't know if you've
had this experience but I don't rage
super hard but I've definitely been that
person who loves my staff but also hates
it when something goes wrong so it's
almost like going like you know like
kicking it across the floor in anger or
throwing it away or whatever aging out
on it but I think it's interesting to
think about how you're creating sort of
an emotional connection to the art of
contact staff via the prop as if you
were sort of falling in love with a
person but the thing you're actually
we're falling in love with was something
else separate from it does that make
sense they're kind of like two out there
like if you like if you love the staff
but that's not that's actually arbitrary
you actually love potentially love the
art of contact staff or fire spinning or
whatever you're into and if you were to
love like I don't know dancing and you
fall in love with the dancer the dancer
is sort of the middle ground to the
actual like you actually are working
toward something else I was thinking
about that and that evolves you know
like you'd learn to hit like a member I
used to love my staff and I can say this
is happening pretty much every two years
I'll hate the staff that I once had like
I'm like man that staff was such a piece
of garbage they can't believe I spun
with that fricking back for two years I
don't know if you have the same
experience but yeah yeah when I think of
my old staffs I'm like there is no way I
want anything with it he's the death
yeah yeah and sometimes I have
destructively destroyed staffs oh yeah
once just once
how did you break it was it against the
tree it's great
why because that way I couldn't I was I
think I was absolutely sure actually I
was quite angry have Flo show and took
it out on the staff yeah yeah yeah it's
like this is well it's freeing about
like acrobatics is that you don't have
to take your prog with you
you just take yourself mmm which is
quite nice after you have to carry like
a big weird shaped bag around for years
and years and years Aykroyd but it seems
like very easy after that yeah how does
it how does a crow fulfill you like well
what do you get out a crow well it's
like it's like some of it it's like
during context a fit with the person
basically so you have like social
contact hmm and doing some kind of
manipulation of a person instead of of a
problem but obviously without having
another person involved it's very
frustrating because you can't just
practice whenever you want which is
what's nice about juggling or like
handstands or solo academics Wow
I just had a really trippy realisation
in this whole love and staff I was just
thinking like you know like contact
staff itself is like I kinda I hate to
say this cuz sort of a sensual prop sort
of like contact juggling has some of
that too in it where basically you are
you are touching yourself contact yeah
and how that sort of like you're just
talking about a crow like with a crow
you know your or contact improv as the
extreme version where you basically a
lot of your contact is with other people
as objects and some like I'm a table you
know I'm this thing I'm just thinking
how staff contact staff or sort of the
contact arts kind of have this thing
where if you're falling in love with the
thing like it is literally like
you're literally building a physical
connection you're waking up the neurons
in your body to connect with this crop
or like what stab you literally are like
being touched in ways you've never been
touched by staff does we got this right
it makes it no I mean it makes I mean I
don't know I just kind of a little a
little a little like a kid use my
contacts back ah well you know what's
cool about contacts to have to just as
putting it out there is that there's a
lot of women into contacts app that is
like that the wildest thing that I've
seen like of the entire like of all the
flow prop movements hoop is sort of like
let's just put that one aside a little
bit but I would say in general of the
movements that tend to be dominated by
males I feel like the contact arts in
actuality at this point is really
dominated by females like as the morse
guild in touch with the prop people like
i just being honest and that's kind of
an interesting thing like I wonder why
that is
I'm just thinking like why do you think
females gravitate to contact staff or
dragon staff even recently to then say
some of the other props do you think it
might be some of that scent that contact
or do you think well yeah maybe also
obviously you've got big strong female
contact efforts a lean sadly Linda as
well I think you've got more like is it
Casey Allen other people in America yep
Annetta who's here obviously he maybe
that's on toiling as well as influence
that in some way but there's not much
overlap I think between context anthem
baton twirling starting to that Lina
really well I've never really seen
anything well I mean let's get it
straight the baton twirlers are trying
on a level that we're not trying right I
mean you know the baton life is not a
life for a flow artist and I think we
all could probably agree for that cuz I
you know after you should check out the
art of the inning with the
you know he's like all I did was was
drilled until I was 13 years old I mean
before that like I had zero creativity I
was like spinning around doing what you
know what was asked to me what was laid
out and you know got more creative once
I had that sort of technique base so
yeah yeah I feel like it's the opposite
amongst uh context athletes first off
they just do whatever they like
and then they start well that was a part
that was really cool I think she
actually was amazed that people just
picking up the sticks could teach like
people with zero educational basis could
actually learn anything was something
she was like kind of impressed with you
know what do you mean like people could
learn it by themselves though people who
could teach it people could learn it by
themselves because baton you know
Annette okay her family is all baton
twirlers she was like bred to be her
right she was literally made to be that
machine it wasn't like it just came out
of nowhere and a lot of our flow people
are making up crazy context tactics but
literally are just watching a video
online and trying it or like there's a
lot of Latin American contact staffers
that haven't gotten out there yet but
there's a ton that are really really
good and and they're just like watching
a video and just like derping and
learning all this crazy stuff that so I
think that was amazing hmm yeah I think
a weave as well especially it's been
very influential in regards of women
staffers I think as well in her
performances you can really see her
research right no I mean yeah yeah I
don't think technically in terms of her
technique she does a lot of research but
in terms of our performance she's like
she really does it really works great um
I feel like Lynda Lynda was similar in
that way too I mean she Linda was super
disciplined in terms of technique as
well
yeah she would she was more like and
that's how I would say like really
thrilling news oh that's why I need
Valerie to make that epic contact staff
video before she decides not to contact
staff at some point
she's also my favs I think this I think
there is something have to do with like
the fact that it's one prop and it's
quite a slow prop I think it allows it
to be a little bit more dancey and
that's why maybe why women gravitate to
it because it's a facility a little bit
more body movement in some ways because
it's just one thing so you can do more
with your body at the same time yeah and
I think that it makes sense that you
know there's a lot of female role models
I mean there's also a lot of male role
model just be honest right it's not just
like there's a lot of male role models
out there for context at but I think the
the equal like in whooping there's a lot
of female role models let's just say it
in that way in a few males right employ
this is good I mean it's all guys I mean
there are women's spinning poi
absolutely they have to make a tech blog
to remind people that that exists which
which i think is valuable for poi but I
think there's not a lot there but yeah
it's really interesting because this or
like bizarre gender prop thing is
something that I've been thinking about
a lot because fans for example mm-hmm
you would think that it would be the
female based sort of prop art when
doodle who's basically the guy that
brought I I mean my words would be
manipulation to fans like because it
really wasn't very much fan manipulation
it was just sort of fan timing grim
first then doodle but bringing that to
fans provided like a male role model and
a female dominated art and then that
that shift is sort of changing to right
where there's still mostly women posting
in the fan group but now their
manipulation based and just I find this
really interesting I suppose II being
here so long and going to the juggling
events and the jug events are still all
men straight up let's just own it at
least in those states and the flow
events are pretty much 50/50 you know
and I think this balance is and actually
and also not just you know that's saying
I'm a binary person but there's also a
whole spectrum of people getting into
flow art stuff I'm just trying to be TZ
you know but but like it's I think
it's really amazing that we can have
that opportunity and flow more than
juggling and you don't have to be very
good like you can feel like you could be
the hero even if you're not that good
and I think that's like that the
downside of floret and the positive part
of it you know you could feel like
you're the best in the world and you
know you're not but there's really no
one to tell you you're not so I think as
well then maybe in lecture in America
but men tend to want to perform less
want to be on display last for like just
the dancing or whatever they're moving
around they would rather demonstrate a
technique in the performance than dance
essentially hmm
you know I mean hmm there's a like
social lead divided thing there um maybe
that's why it's more than dominated by
women in that regard yeah that's cool
well obviously obviously performance
performers and performance is a
self-selected in some case cuz you're
not gonna see something on stage that
doesn't want to perform hmm well Michael
we are approaching the end of our
interview and then we can talk for a
minute afterwards but do you have any
last messages to the staffers of the
world the five that might be watching
this and the hundred that will watch it
three years from now do you have any do
you get work I guess nice yeah people
who see the research looking for the
more I think there's something to be
said for trying to find luthervision
play yourself but nobody's really self
talk you might as well find out what's
going before you and build on top of it
right yeah I think that it's so
interesting yeah that's swagger when you
get started a feeling like the best and
that hunger sometimes turns to I'll be I
mean this is much so must be like books
on this but like the jealousy of the
people that came before
for you that are automatically better
than you and trying to blaze a new path
is sort of always like a weird balance
in our community I think you know yeah
that's a bit like that but it's a bit
also like it wasn't really an angel rule
when I started spinning and now people
start with blowing a devil like you're
saying like the people one devil almost
the first middle and you know they'll be
even had a name for a halo role when I
started spinning he had spent six months
letting it convey about you know they
should feel happy that they're getting
to build on other people work you don't
have to go through this scenes of
blindly searching for one trick that's
super basic to what we can what we know
nowadays basically hmm yeah yeah well
and a lot of that work was thanks to you
and you know people in Sandy and
everybody else least when I was starting
Benjamin and everybody else posting in
the old Benjamin what each half of the
intro separately and then we had to let
off each other to connect them up yeah
yeah so well thank you Michael for your
time
we I'll still stick around but I'm going
to turn off the thing now well thank you
for being a guest on my well what thank
you know Ellis oh thanks yeah okay I
hope to still be around eventually in
the future and say goodbye